Je pense que je suis un des premiers informés
de l'attentat du World Trade Center
par la rapidité de sortie du ministre.
La façon dont est sorti Alain Richard
puis Hubert Védrine indique
qu'il se passe quelque
chose de très grave.
Je suis seul ce jour-là
dans les couloirs de l’Assemblée
parce que les médias mainstream
globalement ne s’intéressent
pas à ce type de sujets.
C’est vrai que quand vous partez
sur ce type de commission
vous n’avez pas le sentiment
que vous allez faire un scoop.
François Léotard n’intéresse
pas grand monde
la Macédoine encore moins
et évidemment personne,
quand les députés, les ministres
rentrent dans la salle,
on ne se doute pas un seul instant
qu’il est en train de se jouer
un drame planétaire
qui va faire basculer le monde.
" De l’autre côté de l’Atlantique,
2 boeings kamikazes
viennent de percuter
les tours du Wall Trade Center.
Il est 9h du matin à New-York.
L’audition est suspendue, les ministres
s’éclipsent pour rejoindre Matignon
les députés eux découvrent
ces images stupéfaits. "
D’abord le ministre de l’Intérieur
va sortir en courant avec son aide de camp.
Puis le ministre des Affaires Étrangères
puis les députés
se ruent vers la télévision.
Il y a un silence de cathédrale
je suis en contre-champ, parce que
j’ai besoin de voir leurs visages
et en même temps j’ai la curiosité
moi-même de regarder cette télévision
donc je me décale légèrement,
je m’en souviens très très bien, et je vois
une des tours jumelles qui s’effondre
puisqu’à ce moment-là,
la deuxième n’est pas encore tombée.
Et donc j’ai la Commission de la Défense
au cœur de ce sujet
qui regarde stupéfaite ces images
qui sont hypnotiques
qui sont déroutantes…
et plus rien n’existe.
"- Épouvantable,
c’est épouvantable."
" - Les Américains vont vivre ça
comme un deuxième Pearl Harbour.
C’est le sommet du terrorisme."
Aujourd’hui, immédiatement
le journaliste pourrait envoyer un tweet
et informer la planète entière
dans l’immédiateté!
Moi je suis en train de filmer, je ne peux
rien faire d’autre que de filmer.
C’est une autre histoire
c’est du journalisme à l’ancienne.
Et on est en 2001.
La chaîne est plus que jeune,
c’est un nourrisson.
Il faut se légitimer
à l’égard des députés
il faut se légitimer à l’égard
de l’institution des fonctionnaires.
Ce n’est pas simple
mais cette séquence, je ne sais pas
si elle fait avancer l’image de LCP
mais incontestablement
elle donne l’image d’une chaîne
qui est sur le coup,
qui est là et qui réagit.
Il ne se passe pas
grand chose pour être honnête
en termes de matière journalistique.
Il se passe même rien
mais il se passe cet instant
qui dure une éternité en fait.